[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrée à la situation sécuritaire au
mali et plus largement au sahel au
lendemain de la mort du bk ibrahim
boubacar keita l'ancien président chassé
du pouvoir par les militaires en 2020 la
junte évoque les mots accumulée pendant
son règne violence djihadiste
communautaire ou crapuleuses faillite
des services de l'état ou encore
corruption mais depuis quelques mois une
partie de bras de fer s'est engagé avec
cette jarne justement au pouvoir qui va
des sanctions des pays de l'afrique de
l'ouest soutenue par la france aux
menaces de retrait des forces militaires
européennes de la région le tout dans un
contexte de guerre froide et de présence
paramilitaires en russe alors quelle est
l'ampleur de la menace terroriste
comment la présence militaire française
évolue tel quel et l'intensité de la
force paramilitaire russe wagner au mali
le sahel est il une poudrière on en
parle avec mes invités et nos
chroniqueurs voici menace qui est avec
nous bonsoir voici journaliste
chroniqueur france24 spécialiste des
réseaux jihadistes bienvenue dans le
débat gauthier rybinski est avec nous
bonsoir gauthier georges tron hooker
internationale france 24 nous avons
également à bamako avec nous cyril payen
un grand reporter envoyé spécial de
france 24 à bamako au mali bonsoir cyril
est également ya gagne à galets bagayoko
qui est avec nos docteurs en sciences
politiques présidente de l'african
security secteur network hauteur de le
multilatéralisme sécuritaire africains à
l'épreuve de la crise sahélienne c'est
publié par le centre francophone de la
chaire raoul dandurand
bonsoir nyaga les bagayoko et merci
encore d'être avec nous tu as vu le truc
derrière
on va démarrer ce débat en essayant
justement de cadrer cette question
sécuritaire au mali et au sahel wassim
avec vous d'abord depuis l'avancé des
groupes jihadistes dans le nord du mali
on parle de 2012 et l'intervention de la
france en 2013 quelle est la présence
des jihadistes aujourd'hui au mali et au
sahel et quelles sont les zones les plus
dangereuses bon en fait les jihadistes
ont été chassés par le person serval des
centres on va dire urbain dans le nord
du mali mais petit à petit ils ont
refait leur leur toile et se sont
étendus jusqu au centre aujourd'hui à
des opérations dans les alentours de
bamako et même à la frontière avec les
pays limitrophes comme côte d'ivoire
togo et c'est donc la pression militaire
française effectivement les a chassés
ils ont ils ont perdu leurs assises on
veut des territoriales qui était très
éphémère sauf que il se sont
reconstitués si on parle d'al qaïda sous
l'emblème de jama pour saddam ou sliimy
en 2010 est donc un agglomérat de
groupes djihadistes unifiée sous le
commandement d'aqmi et qui a réussi à
s'implanter dans le tissu local d'une
manière assez on va dire assez réussie
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
et qui donne du fil à retordre en tout
cas au gouvernement malien successives
au pays des mythes rohff et à la force
barkan s'ajoute à cela inséré dans le
paysage local ça veut dire qu'en fait la
population finalement fait avec
on va dire là la population elle est
entre le marteau et l'enclume ça veut
dire les états ne sont pas présents il
ya deux groupes djihadistes y allaient
en venir y al qaïda l'état islamique qui
sont en guerre entre eux il ya un qui
est moins on va dire aujourd'hui dans
l'état des choses moins violent -
jusqu'au boutiste que l'état islamique
c'est al-qaïda et les populations pour
certaines se sont retrouvés obligés de
choisir un camp entre ces deux camps
parce que à part ça pour les forces
armées gouvernementales elles sont vues
comme on va dire prédatrice pour ces
mêmes populations donc aujourd'hui on a
par exemple al qaïda qui fait de la
politique qui prend l'once descendez qui
fait justice aussi sur les moindre truc
et qui entre dans ce tissu local par
exemple ils essaient de gagner le coeur
les esprits aborder les choses comme
elles sont des notables des chefs de
tribus j'essaie de les ménager il ya
plus de l'application de la charia
extrême coupé mais des mains et des
pieds comme en 2012 ils font de la
politique in fine et ils ont annoncé
qu'ils négocier voulait négocier avec le
gouvernement malien le gouvernement
solide car on en parlait avait annoncé
cool et négocier avec eux ils ont même
annoncé c'est inédit que le territoire
français est exempt d attentat qui n'a
jamais eu depuis le mali et qui en aura
jamais donc c'est important ils font de
la politique d'un autre côté on a l'état
islamique a eu sa montée en puissance
depuis 2015 et qui étaient contenues sur
zone à cause de sa guerre avec al qaïda
à cause de la pression
barkan mais qui n'a pas l'implantation
locale car al-qaïda aujourd'hui appelé
plusieurs décennies on va dire
d'existence aujourd'hui on va dire le
vivier pour schématiser des recrues de
l'état islamique se retrouvent tillabéri
au niger et ils ont pas vraiment de
d'assises par exemple au mali encore
peut-être un peu plus au burkina faso
mais ils n'ont pas cette assise
populaire car aujourd'hui al qaïda parce
qu'encore une fois qu'il fait de la
politique alors justement gosteli bécane
qui est décédé hier il reprochait lui à
la france de l'avoir lâché
c'est compliqué parce que ib qu'à lui
même a changé plusieurs fois
quand ils arrivent au pouvoir après
avoir passé un certain nombre d'années
dans l'opposition après avoir été un
homme en vue puis voire rétrograde
rétrogradé c'est quelqu'un qui dès
qu'ils arrivent au pouvoir donnent
l'impression d'avoir une sacrée poigne
et une sacrée fermeté et d'une certaine
1012 d'une certaine façon la france
notamment dans la répression de révolte
estudiantine de choses de ce type même
de dans l'est dans les conflits inter
inter-claniques on va dire et la france
reste sur cette idée sur l'idée que
ibrahim boubacar keïta est un homme à
poigne et quand il est démis arrêtez
donc en 2020 il présente d'ailleurs un
message dans lequel il dit voilà je
démissionne je n'ai plus les moyens de
continuer un politique qui imagine les
autres la cedeao comme la france qu'il a
été contraint de se prononcer de la
sorte or quand la cedeao fait pression
pour qu'ils soient relâchés
goodluck johnatan l'ancien président du
nigéria dieu je suis désolé mais j'ai
l'impression que imeca n'a pas été
contraint de se retirer pourquoi je vous
dis ça parce que le problème c'est que
ensuite la france va se dire ouh là
qu'est ce qu'on fait là qu'est ce qu'on
a on a joué la carte ib cas il n'est
peut-être plus à la hauteur pour x
raisons il n'avait plus envie de
s'engager dans cette chose là on
rétropédale et on attend de voir ce qui
va se passer après et ça c'était voilà
par rapport au personnage libé cas c'est
une attitude de la france mais clark qui
à remettre dans une globalité c'est que
la france est toujours
soumise à des demandes contradictoires
si elle en fait trop elle est le facteur
néocolonialistes et on le comprend
aisément et si elle n'en fait pas assez
elle est jugée comme étant responsables
ou même complice des actes des
djihadistes donc cesser si vous voulez
pour une une présence française qui se
veut sécuritaire c'est un peu compliqué
de faire face à des contradictions
politiques de ce type là compliqué donc
depuis il faut dire c'est la junte qui
est au pouvoir au mali cyril vous êtes à
bamako à ces rites païens d'abord quel
est le sentiment de la population
malienne que vous rencontrez est ce
qu'elle craint pour sa sécurité est ce
que la menace djihadiste par exemple est
la première préoccupation des maliens
écoutez pour être très franc à bamako
qui est une bulle sécuritaire à c'est
bien connu c'est sûr sans doute là la
seule enclave à peu près sécurisée du
mali franchement non bien qu'on sente
effectivement qu'il y à cette pression
et wassim le disait très justement avec
des combats qui ces dernières semaines
se sont dangereusement rapproché de la
de la capitale mais il faut bien se
rappeler que c'est un pays absolument
immenses sans doute d'ailleurs trop
grand et le plus grand pays d'afrique de
l'ouest avec des milliers de des
centaines bardon de kilomètres qui
séparent le je me trouve bamako par
exemple de tessalit tu as la frontière
algérienne près de 2000 km mais aussi
des ans des endroits de l'azawad un
traditionnellement touareg qui semble
réellement et c'est le sentiment ici
pour répondre à votre question
appartenait à un autre monde avec des
considérations ethniques linguistiques
et social donc non il n'y a pas ce
sentiment d'insécurité mais on sent que
c'est le dernier verrou sécuritaire et
il est vrai que j'ai peur pour ma part
passé trois séjours ces deux derniers
mois au au mali et bamako depuis
depuis il ya trois semaines et bien a
radicalement changé et ce qui a changé
en tout cas ici dans les rues outre ces
deux sentiments de d'incertitude 1 vers
l'avenir et bien c'est le marqueur
important qui a été
la grande manifestation à l'appel du
gouvernement de transition à l'appel du
colonel simi koïta vendredi cas de
manière inédite rassemblé des dizaines
de milliers de deux personnes de maliens
dans les rues de la capitale mais
également dans les rues des grandes
villes du pays à kidal à gao et
tombouctou ça c'était la grande surprise
et ça va sans doute faire effet d'un
marqueur sur la sécurité aussi puisque
les faits le lendemain de cette
manifestation est bien qu est-ce que ce
vin se lavait va va amener ce que ce
sont les lendemains qui chantent
certainement pas le pays est
complètement enclavé il y à des
questions sur la coopération militaire
on en parlait à l'instant qui se posent
et cela n'échappe pas évidemment aux
millions de maliens qui ont eu depuis
près de dix ans l'habitude d'avoir cette
coopération militaire avec la france la
plus grosse opération extérieure
française qui peine on le voit à se
réinventer c'est un scénario un peu
difficile pour la france aujourd'hui de
se redimensionner dans un contexte
politique extrêmement tendue dont bafia
il ya énormément d'incertitudes c'est
beaucoup plus palpable qu'il ya encore
quelques semaines même encore une fois
dans cette bulle sécuritaire qui est
bamako où finalement bon an mal an on
arrive à survivre sans avoir les et les
asturies terre c'est à dire le déficit
total d'états que l'on peut voir
ailleurs dans de grands noms dans une
grande majorité il faut le dire voire
les deux tiers du mali niagalén bagayoko
en 2012 les français avaient été
accueillis comme des héros ils ont
libéré tombouctou des djihadistes
comment en fait les djihadistes ont-ils
résisté à cette présence militaire
française au sahel on parle donc de plus
de 5000 hommes comment l'expliquer
alors c'est en 2013 est en réalité que
sont après revenus les troupes
françaises en réaction à l'offensive à
la fois djihadistes rebelles touareg qui
avait en effet été lancée à partir de
2012 dans un contexte de vide politique
à bamako puisqu'un coup d'état avait
renversé le président amadou toumani
touré
les troupes françaises ont en effet été
acclamé on se souvient de ces images
notamment de françois hollande à
tombouctou et notamment parce que l on à
l'époque réussi à atteindre leur
objectif externe extrêmement clair qui
visait à libérer les villes du nord
kidal tombouctou gao sous l'emprise des
groupes djihadistes mais la
transformation de l'opération serval qui
était uniquement circonscrite au
territoire malien en opération bar kahn
dont le mandat est beaucoup plus large
et s'étend sur 5 pays du sahel a tendu à
rendre beaucoup plus difficilement
identifiables les objectifs de cette
opération qui a indéniablement obtenu un
certain nombre de succès tactique mais
qui n'ont jamais réussi à être convertis
en victoire stratégique est en réalité
c'est cette incapacité qui a beaucoup
suscité de doute de scepticisme puis
aujourd'hui de l'exaspération voire de
la colère qui explique qu'il y ait une
impatience vis-à-vis de la présence
française un patient ce qui devient une
véritable hostilité puisque je pense
qu'il ne faut pas considérer que toutes
les manifestations
contre la présence française sont
uniquement manipuler soit par des
groupes patriotes soit par des
puissances étrangères comme la russie
pour ne pas la nommer les maliens ont
une conscience politique font des choix
de manière tout à fait assumée et
aujourd'hui la présence française mais
plus largement la présence
internationale on voit que des
difficultés se posent de nouveau avec la
minus mas est au coeur de leurs
revendications
voici ma alors justement après ce que
vient de dire ni à galets bagayoko la
france elle doit partir où elle doit
rester le ministre des affaires
étrangères malien demande à revoir les
accords de défense oui absolument
c'est par où elle reste sert ans en
répondant à l'une de mes questions donc
dimanche hier kim a très clairement dit
que l'afp que le mali a demandé
officiellement à la france de revoir le
traité de défense parce qu'ils
estimaient qu'il qu'il était en
contradiction avec la constitution
malienne que ça empêcher les forces
aériennes malienne d'aller où elle
voulait et c'est donc j'ai pu confirmer
cela avec les autres les autorités
françaises plusieurs sources qui m'ont
dit effectivement il ya une demande qui
a été soumise fin décembre et qu'elle
est à l'étude donc ça a eu lieu après on
ne sait pas ce qui va être négocié en ce
qui concerne par exemple
ce qu'il a dit pas pour iliad et l'armée
de l'air ne pas aller à certains
endroits on m'a expliqué très clairement
c'était les accords de les conflits
ctions l'armée de l'air malienne vol
depuis peu depuis un an et à des tous
canaux ou des petits avions et que
évidemment quand ils vont aller sur une
zone où barkan opérationnel avec
plusieurs aéronefs il faut coordonner
cela on dit que ça s'arrêtait là et puis
dans les faits cette demande de revoir
les accords n'a pas eu d'impact sur la
présence française alors on parle
aujourd'hui sur le terrain donc il ya eu
plus de 30 vols de barkan en soutien aux
forces armées maliennes aux forces
armées du niger et à la minus main et
piquant depuis 48 heures il ya eu quatre
opérations conjointes avec les femmes un
takouba forces spéciales européennes
dans la région du banat kahindo liman en
particulier dans les dernières 48 heures
il ya 200 forces spéciales italienne qui
sont arrivés avec leurs hélicos et qui
sont opérationnels depuis le 15 et aussi
à les danois qui arrivent dans les jours
dans les jours à venir donc dans l essai
doit disent qu'ils veulent retirer leurs
forces ils doivent retirer leurs forces
mais il y en a d'autres qui arrivent en
gros donc pour le moment le seul impact
il est sur la minus l'environnement et
sur les forces de l'onu qui voient leur
avion collé au sol depuis vendredi il ya
eu de négociations aujourd'hui entre la
minus main et les oatei malienne qui ont
échoué m'a-t-on dit et à quelques il ya
quelques heures et finalement les avions
sont restés cloués au sol aujourd'hui et
demain exception faite des vols on va
dire médicaux sachant que la minus main
c'est elle qui convoie les militaires
maliens les forces de l'ordre mondial
quand ils sont blessés et a eu plus de
200 convoyage sur 2021 donc c'est une
situation assez particulière aujourd'hui
au la minustah et les forces de l'onu se
trouve collé au sol et subissent en gros
bras de fer entre paris et bamako et
ceux qui payent le prix au mali ce sont
finalement les maliens qui profite de la
présence d'un virus mois que ce soit au
niveau humanitaire au niveau médical ou
au niveau basique de la vie de tous les
jours et là on leur en privent
exactement
gauthier est ce que la france doit
rester ou partir
à vous avez combien d'heures devant vous
je veux dire par là que bien si on
reprend les choses
vous inquiétez pas gauthier les
saucissonner mais répond si vous
permettez donc sur la notion de
gouvernance parce que c'est là dessus
que les choses ont commencé à se gâter
il est évident que ce que la france a
montré des lots mali et ailleurs c'est
une incitation à suivre un modèle
qu'elle même ne suis pas inquiet comme
qui est présenté comme une jolie
danseuse et qui n'est pas susceptible
d'être atteint par les populations ou
par leurs gouvernants et encore moins
grâce aux truchement des français et ça
c'est capital dans la sphère malienne
c'est que vous avez maintenant une
génération de politiques maliens qui
vous disent oui le démocrate chine
peut-être pas pourquoi pas enfin ça
n'est pas un impératif catégorique c'est
quelque chose qui est susceptible d'être
contingents et que l'on peut rejeter et
ça c'est sans doute la chose la plus
délicate est la plus dommageable c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des termes qui
devrait s'imposer eux mêmes et qu'ils
sont considérés comme étant en fait des
produits d'exportation occidentaux ou
plus particulièrement français comme la
démocratie et ce relativisme finalement
nuit à l'essentiel c'est à dire à ce qui
doit profiter aux maliens partant la
réponse à votre question sur le fait de
savoir si les français doivent rester ou
partir c'est un peu compliqué vous avez
vu j'en terminerai là vous avez vu
qu'ils ont poussé des cris d'orfraie que
d'orfraie quand il ya eu la présence du
groupe magnat russe et que aujourd'hui
la france se dit bah tiens finalement il
faudrait peut-être voir comment on peut
sans se marcher sur les pieds rester là
donc voilà la réponse elle est encore
mouvante bien sûr cyril est encore
mouvante la réponse est un sentiment
anti français assez fort vous en parliez
d'ailleurs cyril j'imagine que vous le
ressentez encore à bamako là où vous
êtes est ce que la france devrait rester
ou pas lorsqu'on est sur le terrain
comme vous et quels sentiments sur place
et avec justement cette force russe
wagner qui est présente également au
mali la france avait dit c'est eux ou
nous alors où en est on
va écouter pour continuer le tour de
table oui c'est vrai que là là là l'état
major français est dans une position
quasi schizophrénique c'est d'ailleurs
de l'aide de l'est de l'aveu même de
membres de l'état-major qu'on a pu
consulter qu'ils nous disent que c'est à
cs c'est un peu compliqué quand l'état
français à mener cette diplomatie des
rites des lignes rouges ces lignes
rouges et bien elles sont franchis un
c'était le chronogramme électoral
c'était le groupe wagner les coopérants
russe un certain nombre de mesures qui
ont été toutes façons complètement
dépassé alors c'est vrai que quand on se
demande où on en est aujourd'hui
quand on voit que cette crise politique
extrêmement profonde qui est ici on
utilise beaucoup et les maliens sont
volontiers poète la parabole du vieux
couple ils disent que nous sommes pas en
divorce mais nous avons une crise une
crise après tant d'années de devis de
vie commune c'est comme ça qu'on le
prend de manière un peu amusantes mais
certainement il y à cette diplomatie
plume acide et le des lignes rouges qui
a fait long feu et la redéfinition de
l'opération française mais également de
la coopération européenne qui est
extrêmement important qui est sur la
table est vraiment au pied du mur
aujourd'hui alors il est vrai que le
sentiment anti français n'est pas un
sentiment anti français parce que je
peux vous dire qu'ici ça ça n'a pas
changé il ya une véritable entente avec
la population malienne à bamako c'est
vraiment le rejet qu'on a pu voir
pendant 10 notamment dans les rues de
bamako et du mali c'était le rejet de la
gouvernance française le rejet de la
politique française et en l'occurrence
qui avait été stigmatisé par
l'engagement militaire français pourquoi
et bien parce que certainement
les gens ne comprennent pas ici où elle
anime et on que la barca nous parle
l'état major français n'a pas
nécessairement bien communiquer sur les
bons résultats qui avait sur le terrain
dans cette lutte anti djihadistes qui
mobilise je le rappelle plus de 5000
personnes enfin 4008 4800 personnes
aujourd'hui l'opération aux lointaines
et cher de plus en plus impopulaire en
france mais n'a pas su communiquer sur
les résultats tangibles et les
populations maliennes mais également du
sel 1 je pense au niger je pense au
burkina faso n'ont pas nécessairement et
bien fait le lien entre ce déploiement
technologique quand on est en plein
désert et quand on voit des convoi de
plusieurs dizaines de blindés un grand
renfort de technologie on ne comprend
pas comment il y a ce ces chiffres assez
incroyable bien de deux populations
civiles qui sont massacrés on parle de
centaines depuis le début de l'année
donc si on met ça l'un et l'autre on ne
comprend pas très bien ce décalage entre
le fond et la forme entre les intentions
et le résultat donc tout cela évidemment
instrumentaliser ou pas ça aussi de la
source on ne sait pas mais il ya un fond
assez peut-être minoritaire mais en tout
cas qui fait beaucoup parler de lui un
kit rang qui que traduit ça en
sentiments anti politique français c'est
réellement en tout cas aujourd'hui dans
le collimateur c'est ce que j'essaie de
dire en préalable c'est qu'on voit que
ça a beaucoup changé depuis 48 heures
ici à bamako puisqu'elles étaient
cinquante mille personnes a rejeté la
france a rejeté sa certainement pas
forcément à raison mais a rejeté tous
les torts sur le sur la politique
française donc c'est une crise de couple
je dirais mais ce que ce qui est perçu
ici auprès du gouvernement de transition
nous avons pu rencontrer quelques
éléments dans la journée c'est que
derrière cette surenchère verbale cette
guerre des mots il y a une volonté
d'apaisement de dialogue certainement
donc tout n'est pas perdu encore une
fois le divorce c'est ce qu'on entend
ici ne semble pas vouloir être prononcée
au moment où je vous parle il ya galles
et bagayoko le divorce n'est pas
prononcée encore mais quel rôle
finalement doit jouer la france
aujourd'hui au sahel et puis justement
quel rôle avec où sont les russes parce
que les russes manifestement sont
présents les parages forces
paramilitaires wagner même si moscou
dément d'un côté que les autorités
maliennes reste encore ambigu est-ce qu
effectivement la france pourrait rester
avec une présence russe elle l'a dit que
non au départ comment ça va se passer
alors tout d'abord quant à cette
question de la crise il savoir si la
france doit rester ou partir il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui il y as tu ce
extrêmement profonds entre d'un côté une
présence et une coopération militaires
qui se poursuivent à la fois dans le
cadre du partenariat militaire de combat
mais aussi dans le cadre du partenariat
militaire opérationnelle c'est-à-dire en
termes de coopération de formation
notamment et d'autre part la relation
diplomatique est extrêmement dégradée et
moi il me semble que aucun des deux
partenaires aujourd'hui n'est en mesure
de reconnaître que le sens de cette
présence militaire française n'est plus
en accord avec les lignes diplomatiques
qui sont développés de parts et d'autres
aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur les
objectifs véritablement poursuivi par
l'opération marque anne au delà bien sûr
un des théories du complot je ne parle
absolument pas de ça mais est ce que
l'objectif premier reste la lutte contre
le terrorisme
est-ce qu'il s'agit plutôt dans le cadre
de la stratégie d'un visibilisation de
la présence poursuivi par la france
est-ce qu'il s'agit en priorité de faire
monter en puissance les armes et
sahélienne de les mettre à portée de
l'ennemi alors même que cet ennemi n'a
jamais été apportée de l'armée française
on s'interroge véritablement d'autre
part pour ce qui est de l'arrivée de ce
groupe wagner je pense qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de savoir de
quelle façon se décline la coopération
militaire russo malienne quel est
exactement le statut légal de cette
société quels sont les liens qui la
relie au kremlin et comment la russie
sous traitent en réalité un certain
nombre de tâches mais ce qui est évident
c'est que les lignes rouges en effet qui
ont été fixées dans doivent interroger
sur la question fondamentale de savoir
si la russie est un partenaire
international en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme
c'est la première question et d'autre
part de savoir si un certain nombre
d'acteurs dont on sait qu'ils commettent
des exactions sur d'autres théâtres
peuvent être appliquées aux côtés des
troupes russes dans cette lutte contre
le terrorisme wassim les russes
effectivement protège-t-il les autorités
maliennes l'utile contre le djihadisme
on a montré des images sur france 24
pour montrer qu'effectivement il y avait
une présence des forces wagner au mali
que font-ils est ce qu'on en sait un peu
plus bas côté on a même dévoilé leur
présence au mali en annonçant qu est le
premier combat le 3 janvier entre eux et
les djihadistes dakota est donc un un
des instructeurs qui accompagnait les
femmes 1 dans le centre du mahdi ils
sont confrontés avec les jadistes
lui-même le premier mot russe à ce
moment là donc on sait qu'ils sont là
mais comme l'a très bien dit bien galets
on sait pas quelle est leur qualificatif
quoi est ce que ce sont que des
instructeurs est-ce qu'ils appartiennent
à l'armée russe parce qu'on sait qu'il
ya des mécanos de l'armée russe qui ont
été envoyés à tombouctou mais ça vient
de décliner canaux de l'armée russe ça
veut dire quoi pour aider à rendre les
militaires officiellement les hélicos
voilà des unités militaires russes donc
exactement et ongles à force daguenière
faut expliquer c'est une force
paramilitaire en fait mais pas vraiment
reconnue par le risque ou connaissent
qu'on se consacre de dire aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya les deux et que le flou
est entretenu évidemment par moscou et
par le gouvernement malien parce que in
fine et à quoi bon mettre toutes les
cartes sur la table s'il ya exactions
s'il ya échec comme au mozambique parce
que wagner a échoué au mozambique face à
l'état islamique les russes vont s'en
dédouaner s'il ya des gains à récolter
comme en afrique centrale un public
centrafricaine bas ils vont le
revendiquer mais il faut pas oublier par
exemple que la présence de wagner en
libye c'était un échec aux côtés de la
star même si même la france aussi avait
soutenu after finalement il n'est pas
arrivé à ses fins il faut rappeler aussi
et moins je pense donc ils ne sont pas
si puissants ils sont pas suffisants
mais il faut regarder à mon humble avis
hein il faut regarder du côté de ce qui
s'est passé en syrie avec les russes il
ya eu wagner dans l'est pour embêter les
américains les americans ont tapé très
fort
moscou n'a pas réagi moscou a déployé
wagner en séries mad appelé l'armée
régulière face aux rebelles et à
djihadiste et la police militaire qui
sont des musulmans tchétchène ils ont su
jouer et retourné des rebelles et faire
toute une brigade la 5e brigade de
rebelles syriens qui sont aujourd'hui du
côté du régime donc les russes
aujourd'hui on m'a dit je pense qu'ils
vont essayer de déployer un scénario
similaire en attirant peut-être certains
faction touareg dans nord dans leurs
rangs et essayer de s'implanter
durablement
mais c'est une histoire qui est en
évolution
ils avancent leurs pions petit à petit
et y'a rien qui les obligent aujourd'hui
à dévoiler la nature réelle de la
présence mais en tout cas ils sont là et
il faut faire avec et les etats-unis à
leurs boîtiers les états unis face à
cela on a bien vu qu'ils avaient voulu
se se désengager et que là dessus est
arrivé là faire des sous marins
australiens et qui a été un grands
reproches faits par la france aux états
unis et d'une certaine manière by dane a
dit bon si on veut raccommoder les
choses on va pas couper totalement
l'aide que l'on fournit à la france sur
le terrain sahélien bon on va là aussi
dans une transition si vous voulez
d'être dans une forme de transition
parce que j'ai lu pardonnez-moi côté
qu'il ya des gros porteurs américains en
fait qu'ils sont là pour aider la force
marc khanne donc ils sont opérationnels
tout à fait à mes sont indispensables
ils sont indispensables totalement
indispensable si ça s'était d'ailleurs
c'est ce que craignait d'ailleurs la
france et que finalement cette affaire
des sous marins est venue a été une
aubaine en quelque sorte a contrario
parce qu'elle permet aux américains de
ne pas aller trop vite dans un
désengagement parce que précisément même
s'il ne voit pas la fin de l'histoire ou
le fin mot de l'histoire ils se disent
que par rapport à la france il ne faut
pas les lâcher à tort ou à raison
simplement je voudrais d'une petite
remarque les plats question qui se
retire non du mali ou du sahel ont alors
un otage s'il on encore voilà il ya
encore un otage et puis si vous voulez
ce que ce que ben haida n'avait compris
c'est que l'intention américaine était
peut-être un peu trop rapide cette
affaire des sous marins ce dès ce dépit
de français survient et permet
finalement aux américains de 10 rounds
se désengage pas tout de suite vis-à-vis
de la france même si et je termine un
mot comme certains européens on a
parfois du mal aussi bien côté américain
que côté par exemple suédois à s'engager
à mettre le doigt dans un engrenage où
les relations paraissent tellement
franco-malien celio africanisé si vous
voulez une sorte de relation assez tueur
incestueuse mais à 3 4 5 ou 6 et bien
dans ce cas là on se dit il vaut
peut-être mieux pas y toucher trop de
manière trop précises parce que c'est
quelque chose qui nous brouille et qui
risquent de me mettre dans des
situations extrêmement dangereuses donc
ils dansent de ce côté là mais on se
désengage pas totalement cyril justement
à bamako que dit tout d'abord la
présence des rues ce qu'est ce que vous
entendez sur place manifestement ils ont
l'air d'être soutenue par un certain
nombre de maliens aujourd'hui les russes
est ce que c'est votre votre sentiment
sur place et puis ces américains
écoutez le soutien des ruches c'est
quand même c'est très difficile d'abord
de manière tangible de l'évaluer il y a
eu des incidents récents ont parlé du
convoi 32 sur la voie sacrée qui a été
pris à partie il ya un mois et demi ce
convoi français qui rament des petits
rats qui est amené de la logistique
depuis le port d'abidjan en traversant
le burkina faso le niger pour rejoindre
gao où il a eu des premiers drapeaux
russes qui ont été qui ont été mis
devant ce convoi français il y avait
beaucoup de drapeaux russes également
dans la manifestation de vendredi
dernier avec des drapeaux français qui
étaient un peu moins mis comme des
pavois enfin un peu moins à l'honneur et
c'est une litote maintenant est ce que
c'est une majorité certainement pas ce
qui est certain c'est que la présence
des russes quel qu'il soit quel que soit
leur nature et bien c'est le secret de
polichinelle c'est le tabou qui perdure
depuis de nombreux mois depuis le 11
août dernier quand on avait eu les
premiers enfin les pressentiments qu'il
y avait sans doute un scénario comme ce
qui a pu se passer en centrafrique
voisine avec l'implantation
lente mais certaine d'une logistique de
mercenaires de wagner avec ce flou
entretenu pendant longtemps en
centrafrique sur qui faisait quoi des
formateurs des coopérants une
coopération
traditionnelle militaires russes ou pas
ensuite bah ça a été belle et masque est
ce que ça va être le cas ici on voit
bien que le il ya ce sursaut anti
politique française qui fait que une
certaine partie de la population est
bien un peu à je dirais un peu pas à
bout de souffle mais un recherche
peut-être deux peut-être de réponse à
des questions sur mes des questions même
existentielles des questions économiques
sociales dans un dans un dans un mali
qui est très enclavée depuis l'adoption
des sanctions de la cedeao depuis depuis
quelques jours où on en parle à l'union
européenne où on en parle à l'onu où ça
se passe assez mal notamment à qu'à
cause du calendrier électoral de données
par le gouvernement de transition eh
bien oui les russes sont vus par une
forme une certaine partie de la
population comme une solution pas une
solution miracle mais peut-être la
solution ce qui est le problème en creux
reste que si l'on peut dénoncer
l'intervention militaire française
le fait d'avoir mal communiqué d'avoir
mal travaillé quelle que soit
l'appréciation beaucoup de voix quand on
discute un peu plus longtemps au delà
des manifestations dans la rue eh bien
ce disque pour passer d'une solution
militaire française à une autre solution
militaire qu elles soient russes ou
autres au mali ne résoudra pas les
problèmes du déficit d'état les
problèmes électoraux les problèmes
économiques la corruption donc on est un
peu dans une dans une impasse où la
libye face il reste les français la
solution miracle qui ne fera qui fera
long feu certainement aussi ce sont les
russes la solidarité c'est que ce qui
est vrai c'est que ça se matérialise un
la présence et la logistique russe
encore une fois quelle qu'elle soit
puisqu'il ya ce flou artistique est
maintenue par bamako et et moscou sur la
nature même de ces avancées d'hommes
humain ici à au mali il n'en demeure pas
moins que ils avancent vite si cela se
confirme qu'il soit wagner ou pas il y
avait une quarantaine d'hommes il ya
trois semaines et l'arbre les évalué à
450 dans quatre bases réparties dans le
nord et nord sud du mali donc tout cela
va très très vite et c'est effectivement
cette solution miracle mais qui est un
peu un miroir aux alouettes a pour
beaucoup de bamakois beaucoup de maliens
quand on engage vraiment la discussion
la vérité c'est que le mali est enclavé
le mali est en crise certainement de
gouvernance bien entendu il y avait
l'arrivée des militaires qui avec un
soutien populaire on l'a vu récemment
mais encore une fois que vas si le passé
quand il va s agir de payer les salaires
il n'y a plus d'argent il n'y aura plus
de liquidités d'ici peu de temps et
c'est ça qui anime vraiment le quotidien
des maliens aujourd'hui nyaga les
bagayoko est ce qu effectivement on
passe une sorte de confrontation avec la
france avec un pays qui devient un pays
de deir en proie à une sorte de guerre
froide qu'elle est russe d'un côté on
parlait des américains qui ne veulent
pas finalement se retirer totalement
probablement parce qu'à une présence
russe est ce que ça devient cela
aujourd'hui le mali et le sahel mais en
général
alors à mon avis de ce point de vue là
il est intéressant de se référer au
triptyque dont pas le nouveau chef
d'état major des armées françaises
général burkhardt qui parle du triangle
confrontation compétition contestation
on voit très bien que les linéaments de
la confrontation donc avec les groupes
jihadistes aujourd'hui n'est absolument
plus ce qui fonde uniquement la
problématique politico stratégiques de
la france au sahel il y a effectivement
ce rôle d'autres acteurs mais qui à mon
avis n'est pas illégitime en tant que
telle la france évoque souvent l'arrivée
de nouveaux acteurs au mali si on prend
le cas de la russie ce n'est absolument
pas un nouvel acteur étant données d'une
part les liens extrêmement étroits qui
avait été tissés dès l'indépendance en
termes de coopération militaire avec
l'urss et les ex républiques socialistes
soviétiques puis en raison des accords
qui ont été conclus aussi bien par le
président amadou toumani touré que par
le président yves et qu'a donc la russie
n'est pas un nouvel acteur il y en a
d'autres comme la turquie par exemple
qui joue un rôle de plus en plus
important au sel les autorités maliennes
actuelle s'inscrivent clairement dans
une stratégie d'élargissement des
partenariats et je pense que la
focalisation de la france sur cet
élargissement et un esprit en réalité
contre-productif j'en viens enfin au
troisième élément qui pour moi est la
clé vraiment le coeur de ce qui risque
de se produire au sahel dans les mois à
venir c'est l'élément de la contestation
on a très bien vu comme le disaient eux
cyril payen ce qu'a provoqué ce fameux
convoi voie sacrée qui a provoqué des
affrontements meurtriers au niger
notamment les populations aujourd'hui
peuvent être saisis de mouvement de
colère qui peuvent entraver
logistiquement opérationnellement et en
réalité politiquement la présence
militaire et politique de la france au
mali il nous reste quelques minutes
justement pour conclure j'aurais fait un
dernier tour de table avec en reprenant
le tir de cette émission est ce que le
sahel est une poudrière aujourd'hui
wassim bas côté salé comme ça c'est
comme ça depuis plusieurs années
maintenant mais aujourd'hui il ya des
facteurs nouveaux donc si je peux me
permettre le facteur nouveau c'est qu'on
a deux groupes djihadistes un état
islamique d'al qaïda al qaïda qui veut
négocier qu'al-qaïda veut négocier
demande aux français de partir bamako
veut négocier avec les djihadistes est à
deux doigts de demander aux français de
partir et les russes veulent bien
remplacer les français sur place il faut
garder ça en tête dire les russes et un
alignement aujourd'hui qui peut paraître
bizarre un hulu ou pas habituel mais la
réalité des choses est la suivante aller
les russes qui sont aujourd'hui présents
ils peuvent tout à fait ouvrir des
négociations avec diada galli ils vont
pas s'en priver il négocie ailleurs avec
les djihadistes il s'en prive pas ils
ont pas des prises de positions dures
dans la guerre contre le terrorisme tels
que les pays occidentaux et avec des
éléments en face d'eux qu'ils veulent
négocier donc ça je pense que ça à
prendre en considération parce que ça
fait partie aujourd'hui de
de l'équation parce qu'on est dans une
situation un peu particulière où les
groupes djihadistes disent on veut
négocié en tout cas al qaïda dont ils
sortent de cette guerre épique sans fin
contre les mécréants et les pays
occidentaux dont la france s'enferme
dans la guerre contre le terrorisme sans
fin alors que les russes ont beaucoup
plus dramatique il faut garder ça en
tête leur présence là bas peut ouvrir
des portes de la sorte poudrière ou pas
oui poudrière parce que je vous rejoins
ce que vient de dire madame paquet ou qu
il ya quelque chose de très précis en ce
qui concerne les russes moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse la liste et on devrait le
faire des faillites des mauvaises
engagements français des exactions même
de l'armée française très bien le
problème c'est que un groupe comme
wagner qui n'est pas répertoriée en
russie puisque c'est illégal en russie
les sociétés de mercenaires c'est quand
même des groupes qui sont faites un
groupe qui est dirigée par un proche de
pikine et qui partage l'idéologie de
poutine ce qu'on appelle l'eurasie
l'eurasie est une supériorité des slaves
sur les autres je veux dire par là que
dans le terme des exactions telles
qu'elles ont été commises en république
centrafricaine par le groupe wagner il y
a le racisme à la base donc on peut
effectivement faire la part des des
faillites et des erreurs des uns et des
autres mais là on y va quand même tout
droit avec le groupe wagner parce que
parce que ces gens là ne sont pas
fondamentalement intéressé ni même de
feignent d'être intéressés par le sort
des maliens ils sont là pour réserver
les prébendes à l'état russe ou à eux
mêmes cyril poudrière ou pas vous avez
une minute en
en une difficile j'aurais juste ramener
c'est un scénario un peu catastrophes en
tout cas pour ce qui concerne la
sécurité
j'en appelle pour ça au travail anti
djihadistes de l'armée française depuis
plus de neuf ans maintenant et poudrière
potentiel oui si les français
et partir puisque c'est quand même dans
l'esprit de certains stratèges de
l'état-major si vraiment ça se passait
encore plus mal politiquement de partir
et d'en rappeler à bien ce que ce qui
était considéré comme un amalgame
complètement décalé le 31 août dernier
quand leur très chaotique où nous étions
en afghanistan des américains et qui
aujourd'hui malheureusement pour
l'engagement français et bien on rejoint
un peu quelques similitudes donc à cet
égard oui poudrière puisque tout cela
ouvrirait le pays sur un avenir un petit
peu difficile ou en tout cas un inconnu
nyaga les à bagayoko poudrière ou pas à
vous concluez merci on three year
absolument sachant que je revois
absolument gauthier rybinski pour dire
que la question du respect des droits de
l'homme et de la protection des
populations sera de toute façon au coeur
du succès qui est à venir est
malheureusement je ne suis pas certaine
que l'ensemble des approches qui ont été
tentés aujourd'hui par la plupart des
partenaires internationaux à l'exception
peut-être de la minus m'a ému cette
protection des populations au coeur de
la proche aujourd'hui le bourbier de ces
liens qui n'est plus malien puisqu'il
s'est étendue au delà de ses frontières
mais avant tout en péril la sécurité des
biens et des personnes
des populations civiles merci beaucoup
inégalée bagayoko d'avoir été avec nous
merci voici mois ci menace trt merci
gauthier gauthier rybinski merci cyril
cyril payen donc et en direct avec nous
de bamako et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi vous restez avec nous à
france 24
[Musique]